DESPITE A SUPREME COURT DECISION
TO KEEP TITLE 42 IN PLACE.
>>> WE BEGIN THIS HOUR WITH
UKRAINE.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY'S ADVISER
SAYS RUSSIA HAS LAUNCHED MORE
THAN 120 MISSILES AT THE
COUNTRY.
IT HAPPENED OVERNIGHT.
A TOP OFFICIAL IN ODESA IS
CALLING IT A MASSIVE MISSILE
ATTACK IN LVIV.
90% OF THE AREA IS WITHOUT
POWER.
THIS IS ACCORDING TO A MILITARY
OFFICIAL THERE, WHO SAID THE
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE WAS
RUSSIA'S TARGET.
AND IN KYIV, THIS.
>> AT LEAST THREE PEOPLE WERE
INJURED IN THAT ATTACK,
INCLUDING A TEENAGER.
KYIV'S MAYOR SAYS HOUSES,
INDUSTRIAL FACILITY AND
PLAYGROUND WERE TARGETED.
TWO PEOPLE HAD TO BE RESCUED
FROM THEIR DAMAGED HOME.
THAT'S WHERE WE FIND BEN
WEDEMAN, THANK YOU FOR YOUR TEAM
BEING ON THE GROUND REPORTING.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US?
>> Reporter: WE UNDERSTAND,
ACCORDING TO THE MAYOR OF KYIV,
16 MISSILES WERE FIRED AT THE
CAPITAL.
ALL OF THEM INTERCEPTED, HOWEVER
IN THIS CASE WHERE WE ARE IN A
HOUSE SOUTHEAST OF THE CAPITAL,
THIS HOUSE A PIECE OF DEBRIS
FROM A FALLING MISSILE HIT RIGHT
NEXT TO IT.
INSIDE THERE WERE TWO MEN,
ELDERLY FATHER AND HIS ADULT
SON.
THEY WERE SLEEPING ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THIS HOUSE, WHICH WAS
HIT AT ABOUT 8:30 IN THE
MORNING.
THEY EMERGED WITH JUST
SCRATCHES.
BUT THE ADULT SON, I SPOKE WITH
HIM, HE TOLD ME THEY HEARD A
MASSIVE EXPLOSION.
THE WINDOWS SHATTERED AND THE
WALLS, AS YOU CAN SEE, JUST
CRUMBLED.
HE MANAGED TO GET OUT, BAREFOOT
AND IT'S VERY COLD AT THE
MOMENT.
NEIGHBORS GAVE HIM SOME BOOTS.
BUT AS I SAID, DESPITE THE
DAMAGE YOU SEE AND THE EXPLODED
CAR RIGHT NEXT TO THE HOUSE, TO
THE LEFT OF THE HOUSE, THEY
EMERGED UNSCATHED.
SO THE AIR DEFENSES SEEMED TO
WORK FAIRLY WELL.
BUT AS YOU MENTIONED, IN FOR
INSTANCE THE CITY OF KHARKIV,
FOUR MISSILES DID GET THROUGH,
HITTING WHAT WE'RE TOLD WAS
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
HERE IN KYIV, 40% OF THE CAPITAL
IS WITHOUT ELECTRICITY.
THE AUTHORITIES ARE TRYING TO
RESTORE THAT AT THE MOMENT BUT
BY AND LARGE IT APPEARS THE GOAL
OF THE MASSIVE STRIKE USING
MISSILES AND DRONES WAS TO HIT
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND, OF COURSE, THE GOAL, IT
APPEARS, IS TO LEAVE THE COUNTRY
IN THE DARK AND COLD AS NEW
YEAR'S APPROACHES.
NOW THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF OF
THE UKRAINIAN ARMED FORCES SAID
THAT APART FROM THE DRONES, 69
MISSILES WERE FIRED AT UKRAINE,
BUT THE AIR DEFENSES MANAGED TO
TAKE DOWN 54 OF TH